well it's finally happened somehow
Marvel Studios figured out how to take
one of its least interesting movie
characters The Mighty Thor and make him
the star of a completely bonkers space
adventure with more laughs per minute
than most recent comedies wasn't ant-man
supposed to be the funny Marvel movie
how the heck did thor ragnarok become
the funny one it has to hide it touch
with you I don't have a phone he doesn't
have a phone send a raven anyway
none of the credits have rolled and the
Easter egg hunts have begun there's just
one big question left to answer what's
it all mean
while you probably get the big overall
kind of stuff like how the good guys won
and the bad guys lost there's still
plenty of Asgardian goodness we can dive
into hold on to your hammers while we
explain the ending of Thor Ragnarok and
before you get your breastplate in a
twist
just remember spoilers for this movie
and possibly future Marvel movies lie
ahead
next up Oklahoma so the realm of Asgard
was destroyed by Sirte
in a fury of fire and hey maybe some
extra fury thrown in for good measure
but as Thor reminds us as the evacuates
as people onto the big honkin spaceship
Asgard isn't a place it's a people and
those people they're going to Oklahoma
probably sure they never mentioned a
sooner sate when they decide to hightail
it to Midgard at the end of the movie
but there's still evidence that Oklahoma
is where they'll make their home in the
next movie in the series Thor for more
Thor than ever before that's because in
2007 the Odinson set up a new version of
Asgard for his displaced people in the
fictional town of Broxton Oklahoma is it
a guarantee that Thor and his pals will
trade their helmets for cowboy hats
certainly not but considering how wacky
and crazy Ragnarok turned out to be the
fish-out-of-water potential for setting
the next door' movie in rural Midwest
America is too great to ignore Heller's
fiery fate near the end of the film
hella rushes into battle against a fire
demon Surtur who brings about Ragnarok
the end of Asgard that's the last we see
of Heller and that means of course that
we never see her actually die that's
important when we don't see characters
bite the dust
that means there's plenty of room for
them to come back in future films that's
even more true for characters of the
immortal variety and Heller who's older
and more powerful than Thor and Loki
both seems particularly immune to the
whole death thing
with what have been the literal goddess
of death and all not only that but she's
other most powerful washes in Asgard so
there's every chance that she's still
alive and kicking we know that Thor's
going to need every Ally he can get when
Thanos comes to town who better to call
for help than his big sister on the
other hand in the comics Thanos is in
love with death and conquers the
universe to prove his devotion to her
considering Heller is the goddess of
death some fans series she will return
not to fight Thanos versus the object of
his affection and a speaking of Panos
the mad Titan appears during the first
post-credit scene Thor and Loki talk
about the future of the Asgardians when
suddenly they're interrupted by the
arrival of a gigantic spaceship we never
find out who exactly that ship belongs
to but it's pretty clear that it's
Thanos his ride and who is the man in
the purple chair is purple it's a magic
glove doesn't like standing up we've
known for years that it'd be the big bad
in the upcoming Avengers infinity war
considering the cosmic nature of Thor
and the rest of his people it makes
sense that there'd be the first to
really encounter him directly
and that's not all in July 2017 polygon
reported on infinity war footage shown
at d23 the biennial Disney fan club
celebration that footage showed a brief
moment of Thor meeting the guardians of
the galaxy out in space
considering that Thanos has unknown
entity to the guardians and that Thor's
cruising around space right now it seems
like a pretty safe bet that Thanos is
going to tangle with the god of thunder
before he makes his way to earth an
infinity war in summer 2018
are you ready for the space gem you
can't have an infinity war without
Infinity stones we've seen these things
floating around the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for years and Thor Ragnarok was
no different we got a look at the time
gem around dr. Strange's neck during his
brief appearance and we saw the space
gem also known as the tesseract or the
Cosmic Cube sitting in the vault on
Asgard just before he grabbed syrtis
crown Loki stopped and took a closer
look at the gem and we never saw just
what he did with it but come on we all
know he grabbed that thing it's Loki
that's what he does when infinity war
rolls around Loki will probably do a
double secret portrayal of his brother
and offer up the gem to Thanos in return
for like a space Duchy or something low
he's basically a jerk prepare for him to
be jerky with the Space Jam again more
mirthful marvel the great thing about
marvel movies is that they can kind of
be whatever they want them to be right
Winter Soldier was a super heroic spy
film ant-man was a wacky heist movie and
spider-man homecoming was basically home
alone with the web-shooters but more and
more of these movies have leaned heavily
on comedy and it's a trend that doesn't
show any sign of stopping
guardians of the galaxy for example
became a gigantic hit despite the fact
that exactly 0 of the characters in it
had any name recognition outside of the
deepest corners of the comic shop did
you care about Groot or Rocket Raccoon
before the first guardians of the galaxy
movie probably not but you do now that's
because both of these films in addition
to all the other wonderful things in two
of their characters special effects and
action set-pieces are also really really
funny
the same goes for Thor if he's your
favorite Marvel Comics character then
you've got some weird taste dude four
works great in an ensemble and Thor
comics have a long history of high
adventure and utter weirdness but for
most people he's just a strong guy with
the hammer and two good burn and
memorable solo movies didn't do much to
change that Thor Ragnarok has flipped
the script it might even be fair to say
that has put Thor on the same level as
Deadpool when it comes to funny
superheroes that fans want to see even
more off if there's one major
explanation we can take away from the
end of this movie it's that Marvel is
probably going to double down on the
funny when it comes to adapting as funny
books to the big screen they don't call
them comics for nothing you know thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're lifting
[Music]